when we spoke over email we mainly spoke
about nootropics so if you don't mind
i'll just ask you a couple sure
questions
when people are speaking about
nootropics on different forums and
subreddits and so on there's a refrain
that there's no such thing as a free
lunch quote unquote is this true what
free lunches exist yeah yeah i mean just
look at
you know so here's how to think about it
with these drugs
the
um a drug is a key
to a lock
it's a shape that fits
a lock somewhere in a part of the let's
say the brain or a functionality that
allows the the protein to work better or
worse than it does
before
you know for some positive outcome
okay
side effects
side effects are because a drug will not
bind just to where it is that you wanted
it to go
there are
a hundred billion
lock
locks in your body all the different
shapes of the thing you're designing a
drug to fit into one of those hundred
million locks
it just ain't so
right there is no one to one perfect
interaction
this drug will probably bind to a
hundred million other places or a
hundred thousand other places in the
body
most of the time it doesn't do anything
but if it happens to bind to the wrong
place or interfere in the wrong way then
that becomes a side effect
so for instance you know a lot of um
a lot of protein receptors are
they might be found in the brain but
they're actually found in lots of other
lots of other cells in the body and
there they do a different function
they have a wholly different function
somewhere else in the body even though
that they're being used in the brain for
one thing they're being used elsewhere
for something else
um so you know you might aim it at the
one in the brain but you know this
little cell population that's expressed
on immune system cells
bound by the same drug causes those
immune system cells to do something
wrong
here's a perfect example of a protein
with dual function
uh the the crystalline
uh
protein
it turns out in the in the eye it helps
form the lens
structure it's the it's the transparent
protein that gives the right refractive
index
to cause light when it comes to the eye
to do that turns out the crystalline
protein is also in the in the gut it's
not looking at anything
there it's an enzyme
what the heck
right i mean it's dual function
but you may if you make a drug against
it here
it might cause the crystal right
so you know it's not to say that these
neurotropics
um
will or will not have side effects but
then there's also this
so that's the first biggest problem is
the second
big problem with with these things that
are aimed at say receptors in the brain
is that you actually have families of
genes
that have related
shapes
and related functions
that have evolutionarily diverged for
different purposes in different parts of
the brain but then you have one drug
that binds not just to one of them but
many of them so thc is a case in point
tetrahydrocannabinol of marijuana you
have lots of thc receptors in your brain
and depending upon your particular
genetics
and where they're expressed in the brain
uh and the brain shape that i talked
about before the morphometrics
you know you can get an effect on one
person
they smoke marijuana and they say it
makes them
uh you know paranoid
and they get nervous and introverted and
the same
marijuana smoked by somebody else
and
they're having a blast
right so it has to do with the receptors
that these molecules are binding then it
has to do with the brain shape then it
has to do with the emotional
history of the individual
as well that can frame
how they experience
something i mean you give marijuana to
somebody who's never had it before out
of the blue and they'll freak out
probably
right or other people know how to how to
manage the reaction so i i don't think
it's a negative that there
some of these things have
side effects it's just that these
neurotropics very often
are not
um they're not clinically studied
right they're not nobody has sat down
like i just mentioned with those icd
codes
and said okay here's what happens to
this person here's and here's the range
of individuals and here's the range of
responses that people can get
um and so it's going to be best given to
this class of individual this
neurotropic
is best for this class of individual
this one is best for that you know i've
looked at some of these reddit forums
and they're all over the map people's
experiences
and not because anybody's telling the
truth or or a lie or trying to push an
agenda it's just that they are not
taking into account
the extraordinary breadth of
human genetics and human physiology
that's out there and so
clinical trials
will be important
for these things to work now look at
psychedelics or uh something like
ketamine
you know before they were party drugs
you know now they're actually being used
because somebody's done a clinical trial
under controlled circumstances and shown
that it works
so the kind of uh let's say folklore of
these drugs
that drove their spread through
let's call them you know the society
has finally
led to somebody looking at them closely
enough to say hey
actually these things do have some value
uh and some of these you know drugs on
various you know schedules of you know
no access or never access are now being
prescribed or will soon be prescribed
and that's a good thing
so
but i think
the people in those communities just
need to be
careful about how much they recommend to
other people what they should or
shouldn't be doing because none of them
are doctors people ask me for
my opinion all the time i get emails
from both cancer patients and and people
in the experiencer community this or
that first thing i say like first or
second sentence i'm not a doctor
i'm not telling you what you should do
i would recommend you go to this or that
kind of a doctor first
but here is my non-medical advice to you
and usually it's be careful
you know don't don't take chances with
something that might irreversibly change
your brain chemistry for instance i've
never done any of the psychedelics even
though
i think it would be amazing at some
point because people
have said it comes back they sometimes
come back and it's changed their life in
some
deep way
well i have a lot of people responsible
that i'm responsible for
and two companies that i advise and my
students etc i don't need to come back
you know next week having changed
my
perspective on life and decide i want to
go
you know live in a cave in tibet
you know um so it's it's
er
i just you know
people should just be careful with their
mental health
um
you know that said i take more than
enough uh prescribed drugs
that even the things that i that i do
have to take
um
are uh
are
you know they have little they have side
effects caffeine
has a side effect so
i told you that well i don't know if i
told you in this much detail but i'm
usually disheartened when i read the
subreddits on nootropics because so many
people have extremely positive
experiences with these like when i say
positive i mean cognitively enhancing
for me they're not they're generally i
almost i don't think i think i've tried
so many and almost none of them
have anywhere near the effects that i
see reported or hear reported
they either have no effect or
they somehow dead in my emotions so for
example with adhd medication i could
focus for hours on end with it but then
i'm nowhere near as creative and i don't
feel like i'm faster maybe caffeine
faster that's right only that's it
right so right do you have any
recommendation i'm sure there are other
people who are much like myself i mean
so for instance um
i'd just be open i don't i don't care um
i have some pretty
serious social anxiety
if i go to a party and um
and i'm just asked to speak
you know do small talk
it freaks me out
and um i just get this you know
this anxiety that i just have to i
literally have to run out of the party
so
i did
so covet if anything was great for me
if i but if i'm sitting at a party with
a bunch of people and i'm talking
science i'm talking about something that
interests me i could stay for hours on
end
right so to to deal with
the
places and the times when i have to be
in public right i'll go give a big talk
and then i have to go to a social event
afterwards and talk with people
usually about just relatively mundane
things
um
there is a there are some social anxiety
drugs that i have to take
the first time i was given it
for whatever reason
it sent me to the hospital
right i took it to the normal dose sent
me to the hospital
uh and uh palpitations and all kinds of
weird stuff
but
the
a few days later i was like i was like
so calm for those couple of days so
there was a positive aspect to it in
talking with the
psychiatrist who prescribed it to me in
the first place he said let's why don't
we try you on really little teeny dose
and turns out that's all i needed
with like nibbling something from a five
milligram tablet like one tenth of it
i get all of the benefit that somebody
else needs
you know five milligrams but that's a so
that's an example of a situation that
there's something about my brain
chemistry whatever that receptor is
whatever the structure of my brain
the complex feedback networks it only
needed a little bit of a dab here
because
i had a better receptor or a stronger
receptor
or something else about my network and
my brain
was more than enough to give me the
effect that somebody else needs 10 times
more
and so
maybe that's the case in point for you
with you know these these self-reporting
reddits
are as bad as a
as an online vote
where the only people who respond are
the ones that were interested enough to
respond
and so
um i you know that's why you do a
clinical trial where
you know where you you don't let people
self-report you basically take a
you know a random group of people and
say what happens to now there's going to
be 10 of people that it works for
great why that 10
so that's the same thing that we do with
cancer research as we look we say 10
responded to this chemotherapy why
so now what we do is we create we try to
develop a diagnostic that calls out that
10
ahead of time so that you know when they
come in the door we have this kind of
cancer do a test ah
drug one is good for you drug two is
good for this other group
same thing for these neurotropics
so you but you need an experienced md
if you want to do it
in a scientifically
careful way to to help you navigate
the the possibilities
i don't have any mine would only be for
enhancements i don't have problems per
se and so it's very difficult because
they're generally trying to treat an
injury a disease a pathology of some
sort
anyway